mais d'abord les rillettes de tours sont
elles meilleures que cette ce que celle
du mans cette question cruciale est bien
certains malades ducobu 19 sont
aujourd'hui incapables de la tranchée et
pour cause des semaines après avoir été
guéri il souffre encore d'un symptômes
liés à la maladie la perte d'odorat
qu'on appelle à nos semis la bonne
nouvelle pour eux c'est que l'odorat
peut revenir grâce à la rééducation
olfactives lucas chopin avec paul boyer
ce café semble n'avoir aucun goût pour
les as atteinte de lakovic 19 au début
du mois de mars
elle perd le sens de l'odorat deux mois
plus tard l'oea ne sont toujours rien ça
fait un peu peur quand même parce que là
ça commence à faire un moment donc ça
fait peur que ça revienne jamais j'ai
pas perdu goût tout de suite ni l'odorat
j'ai perdu environ une semaine après et
c'est venu petit à petit donc un matin
je me suis levé chanter plus mon café
puis après ses revenus
et puis après j'ai complètement tout
perdu tous les autres symptômes liés à
la maladie ont disparu mais cette perte
d'odorat ou à nos semis ne la quitte pas
alors ce matin elle a pris rendez vous
chez un orl pour un diagnostic
au programme des tests pour évaluer ses
pertes de sens je vais vous faire sentir
donc 16 heures et à chaque fois
pour l'odeur que je vais vous faire
sentir vous allez m'indiquer parmi
quatre choix à quoi correspond l'odeur
en quelques minutes le résultat tombe
les ressent les saveurs de base mais son
nez lui est très atteint donc là vous
avez un score de 4 sur scène il ya
quelques sensations mais
pour pertes importantes de l'odorat peut
le dire elle va désormais activement se
rééduquer aux odeurs et ce pendant de
longues semaines
pour le docteur aussedat chaque symptôme
du genre doit être accompagnée d'un
rendez vous chez un spécialiste pour ne
pas risquer une perte définitive de
l'odorat et une explosion du nombre de
consultations pour la noce mis depuis
l'apparition de la colline 19
la plupart des patients retrouvent de
doha néanmoins quand on a une perte de
doha assez longue comme celle ci c'est
très important de faire une rééducation
de fatigue pour se donner toutes les
chances de recouvrer l'honorable jusqu'à
85 % des personnes atteintes d'une copie
de 19 symptomatique souffrirait d'une
baisse de l'aude aura un retour à la
normale dans les dix jours s'opère la
plupart du temps